Oh, you got to love Benjamin Netanyahu
running for his life. That is hilarious.
I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah list.
We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn wudu, how
to pray, how to recite Surah al-Fatiha,
Fajr, Zuhr, Asr, Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud, Tarawih, every prayer
for the rest of their lives, you share
in the reward. When they teach their
children, and their children's children,
the reward continues for you. For just
£100, you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. You can't make this up. Iran
hasn't gone through their ballistic
missiles and the those
drones that are hitting places. No,
they've taken this war to another level.
They've taken it to Lego. Yes, I'm I'm
not joking. This war has become a war of
Lego. It's the way they move it
strategically is absolutely crazy.
Subhan Allah, brothers and sisters,
yeah? It seems like experts are saying
that Professor Young is saying that this
is going to be a war of whoever runs out
of ammunition first. And right now, what
they're specifically looking at and what
they're looking at is the following. The
UAE or the those nations who have
American bases are spending $38
for every pound for every dollar Iran is
doing offensive, they're spending $38
defensive.
Bro, that's nearly 40 times. By the way,
that's not the thing. Here is the video
we're going to watch for ourselves of a
demonstration that they've done.
Absolutely, I mean, what could you say?
Very creative, very creative. They
should get into Hollywood.
>> I mean just from there, I'm not going to
lie.
I I it's
I don't know who thought of this.
Like genuinely, I'm like who would think
it'd be like Can you imagine going to
the commander IRGC? Listen, I got a sick
idea. We're we're going to
intellectually I don't know what LEGO?
If he came to LEGO If I was a commander,
I'd slap him.
I'd say what so sorry? I'd slap him. But
looking at this, if I saw this, I'd be
like my friend, this is very creative.
I'm I'm not condoning it. I'm not saying
I'm not condoning, you know, all this
thing etc. It's it's wrong, the war etc.
but I'm just finding it so it's so damn
creative.
Oh you got to love Benjamin Netanyahu
running for his life. That is hilarious.
So, Benjamin Netanyahu running amongst
rats, I mean him being one of them as
well, is hilarious. It's absolutely
hilarious. But let's carry on.
>> There you go. And this is what Candace
Owens said as well. I'll show you on the
screen as well. No American son or
daughter should die for Israel.
stand down. Go home. Find the
legal means to exit the military. What
is Candace said? stand down.
stand down. That's what she said today.
Stop sending your children. Stop sending
your children to die for these people,
these Zionists. Stop. And not only that,
at the beginning you saw the explosion
on that school that killed 160 plus
Iranian girls. Yes, let's not forget
that. Let's not forget that they did
that intentionally. They targeted the
school because they care about girls so
much. Okay, cuz they've been oppressed
by the hijab. They can, you know,
sexually liberate theirself and go sleep
around whenever you like, whenever you
like, 100%.
So, brothers and sisters, obviously I'm
not going to long it too much, but I'm
not going to I'm being honest. Again,
war is catastrophic. It destroys many
people's lives. Be the innocent people
in Israel, the ones who are wishing for
the genocide to carry on. They're not
our teachers. That's why we condemn it.
We condemn the killing of any Israeli
for that matter. I don't care if he's
she's the pro-Zionist or not. Innocent
men, women, and children should not be
killed. In Iran, 160 plus girls who have
been massacred. And it's a massacre.
What's happening in Gaza? So, we do not
condone violence. But, looking at this
and the way they're using warfare in a
strategic way even on social media
shows that Iran has been having this
edge and been preparing for this for war
for 20 years and we are seeing exactly
what they're doing. And they are moving
very, very smart. It does look like what
the Professor Young said that I think
that Iran's going to win this war. I'll
leave it at that brothers and sisters
till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. This is the
new sadaqah jariyah in town. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in the
Quran a man pleading with Allah to send
him back so he could give sadaqah. Why
sadaqah? Because he knows the weight of
sadaqah. Just £100 you can help teach 20
to 60 people to learn
>> how to perform salah recite surah fatiha
and make wudu. Click the link and donate
now.